marie trintignant et depuis hier dans le
coma dans un hôpital de vilnius en
lituanie pour l'instant on sait
simplement que l'actrice s'est
violemment disputé avec son compagnon le
chanteur bertrand cantat du groupe noir
désir
les circonstances exactes restent floues
amaury guibert marie trintignant était à
vilnius pour le tournage d'un téléfilm
sur la vie de la romancière colette
tournage interrompu
l'actrice est dans le coma depuis
dimanche dans un hôpital de la capitale
lituanienne
une demi-heure après son admission nous
avons décidé de l'opérer afin de retirer
un hématome j'ignore son état à l'heure
où je vous parle mais tard hier soir
elle se trouvait toujours dans un coma
profond sous respiration artificielle
sans aucune réaction cérébrale
marie trintignant serait tombé dans le
coma après une violente dispute avec son
ami bertrand cantat le chanteur du
groupe de rock noir désir lui aussi
hospitalisé
sous l'emprise de médicaments et
d'alcool il aurait poussé la crise dans
une chambre de cet hôtel marie
trintignant serait tombé par terre en se
cognant la tête
la police lituanienne a ouvert une
enquête je peux confirmer à 90% que le
drame est lié à une dispute qui les a
opposés le tournage de colette dirigé
par la mère de l'actrice nadine a été
interrompue la dune principalement fou
l'équipe aussi et le tournage est arrêté
ce soir l'état de santé de l'actrice ne
permet pas d'envisager son rapatriement
en france
en lituanie il n'y a pratiquement plus
d'espoir de sauver marie trintignant qui
se trouve toujours dans un profond coma
victime d'une hémorragie cérébrale
la police locale est en train de boucler
lé enquête et le parquet de paris vient
tout juste d'ouvrir une information
judiciaire à l'encontre du chanteur du
groupe noir désir bertrand cantat
karen delaporte alain thomas et sandrine
rigaud menottes aux poignets tête
baissée bertrand cantat est désormais
aux mains de la justice lituanienne
placé en garde à vue hier le leader du
groupe noir désir a été présenté au
parquet de vilnius
une enquête est en cours si sa
responsabilité se confirme
le chanteur risques créés jusqu'à 15 ans
de cluses et qu'il est jugé sûr classes
venues le soutenir en lituanie les
membres du groupe noir désir sont dans
le désarroi
dépassé par l'ampleur de la tragédie on
veut comprendre ce qui s'est passé
déjà sur place la mère de marie
trintignant ne comprend pas non plus
elle sait aujourd'hui que les heures de
sa fille sont comptés dans un coma
profond depuis dimanche
l'actrice a subi une seconde opération
sans succès la famille trintignant a
porté plainte contre bertrand cantat
pour coups volontaires et non assistance
à personne en danger
la responsabilité du chanteur ne fait
pour elle aucun doute on peut craindre
que effectivement bertrand cantat et
porté des coups violents
marie trintignant et qui ne s'ajuste pas
simplement d'un accident en marche de la
bataille judiciaire qui commence c'est
le sort de marie trintignant qui ce soir
préoccupe tout le monde même si les
médecins estiment qu'il n'y a plus
d'espoir les proches veulent encore
croire à un miracle
menottes aux poignets tête baissée
bertrand cantat est désormais aux mains
de la justice lituanienne placé en garde
à vue hier le leader du groupe noir
désir a été présenté au parquet d'ulm us
une enquête est en cours si sa
responsabilité se confirme le chante
risque est très vrai jusqu'à 15 ans
vivaient tous les juges esclaves venus
le soutenir en lituanie les membres du
groupe noir désir sont dans le désarroi
dépassé par l'ampleur de la tragédie on
veut comprendre ce qui s'est passé
déjà sur place la mère de marie
trintignant ne comprend pas non plus
elle sait aujourd'hui que les heures de
sa fille sont comptés dans un coma
profond depuis dimanche
l'actrice a subi une seconde opération
sans succès la famille trintignant a
porté plainte contre bertrand cantat
pour coups volontaires et non assistance
à personne en danger
la responsabilité du chanteur ne fait
pour elle aucun doute on peut craindre
que effectivement bertrand cantat et
porté des coups violents à marie
trintignant et qu'il ne s'agisse pas
simplement d'un accident en marche de la
bataille judiciaire qui commence c'est
le sort de marie trintignant qui ce soir
préoccupe tout le monde même si les
médecins estiment qu'il n'y a plus
d'espoir les proches exact encore croire
à un miracle
l'avion médicalisé qui transportent
marie trintignant et sa mère nadine
vient d'arriver il ya quelques minutes à
l'aéroport du bourget l'actrice est
toujours dans le coma il durant l'après
midi
le chanteur du groupe noir désir a été
entendu par la police lituanienne de
façon lapidaire il a tenté d'expliquer
les circonstances du drame
agnès garder céline rousseau nadine
trintignant n'a que ses mains pour
protéger le visage de sa fille marie
trintignant toujours dans le coma quitte
l'hôpital de vilnius où elle a été
maintenue artificiellement en vie depuis
dimanche
sur le tarmac l'attend un avion privé
qui doit la ramener à paris
si les médecins lituaniens ont un temps
refusé tout rapatriement ils ont fini
par accéder en début d'après-midi aux
voeux de la famille
sa famille souhaite malgré le caractère
est évidemment irréversible de son état
c'est assez triste à dire mais que
finalement si elle doit mourir sur en
france une autre épreuve les attendaient
déjà ce matin lors de la comparution au
tribunal de vilnius de bertrand cantat
chanteur du groupe noir désir à mort de
marie trintignant auteurs présumés des
coups qui ont plongé l'actrice dans le
coma la laissant la nuit du drame
inanimé jusqu'au petit matin sans
alerter les secours
six heures trop tard il aurait fallu la
mener immédiatement mais les chirurgiens
lituanien a été formidable recevabilité
un lien et toute l'équipe médicale l'ont
suivi je les ai vus faire tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient je les ai vus lutter regardez
un prix le procureur a réclamé un mois
de détention provisoire contre bertrand
cantat évoquant un crime grave
le musicien s'est d'abord tu longuement
avant de déclarer en quelques mots
seulement je vous demande pardon mais
c'est un accident
ce n'est pas un crime l'ambiance est
tendue alourdie par la présence de
photographes et cameramans a qui vont
livre le suspect le tribunal a
finalement décidé de son maintien en
détention jusqu'au 14 août
et selon le code pénal lituanien si
marie trintignant décède
l'auteur des coups pourraient être
inculpés condamnés à 15 ans de prison
ce soir la france n'a toujours pas fait
de demande d'extradition
enfant chéri de la famille trintignant
mari avait commencé à faire ses premiers
pas devant la caméra dès l'enfance une
personnalité au charme énigmatique est
la voix sombre est immédiatement
reconnaissable
une actrice et une comédienne accomplie
une femme de passion de tumulte jacques
chirac en ce soir hommage à celle qui
servait son art avec beauté sensibilité
et intelligence
marianne bonhomme rémy posséder pour son
dernier rôle celui de colette marie
trintignant à travailler en famille avec
sa mère réalisatrice son fils comédien
et son frère assistant réalisateur
le clan trintignant et surtout son père
jean-louis avec qui elle avait des liens
si forts
je crois que petite elle a jamais pleuré
je sais pas je me souviens pas que
qu'elle ait été un moment un problème
souci elle a été que du bonheur
deux pièces de théâtre ensemble poèmes à
lou et conversations sur un quai de gare
michel je m'appelle vichy c'est marrant
comme arthur et qu'est ce que ça a de
marrant
à 4 ans et je voulais être vétérinaire
mais sa mère lui confier un rôle dans
mon amour mon amour qui marie
trintignant a tourné une trentaine de
films elle s'impose en 1992 dans betty
de claude chabrol dans le cri de
l'asseoir 1996 sa beauté et son talent
éclate la salle elle a voulu être
comédienne pour soigner sa timidité
ça aide parce que ce qu'il ya dans le
cinéma la télévision c'était pour elle
le même métier
en 99 et les victoires qui luttent pour
l'avortement c'est que les avortements
clandestins
l'utilisation des sons des aiguilles à
tricoter diverses plaintes et un réel
danger pour les femmes
l'an dernier le chanteur thomas fersen
lui avait écrit une chanson marie cette
boîte très singulière qui qui m'a plu et
puis je sentais que je pouvais écrire
des histoires et surtout elle pouvait
incarner des personnages que je pouvais
d'écrire dans mes chansons
marie trintignant un destin brisé
à 41 ans
ce qu'on retiendra de marie trintignant
une beauté ténébreuse un regard
troublant une voix grave à l'image des
rôles qu'elle a incarné à la télé comme
au cinéma
un parcours alternatif grâce auquel elle
avait su se faire un prénom
elle restera dans nos mémoires notamment
à travers son dernier rôle son dernier
tournage pour france 2 elle incarnait
colette une femme brillante et
passionnée
marie-hélène bono rémy poissonnier son
dernier tournage aura été une affaire de
famille marie a coécrit le scénario avec
sa mère nadine qui réalise également le
film home and calling à son fils de 16
ans interprète bertrand de jouvenel le
jeune amant de colette vincent
trintignant le frère de marie et premier
assistant réalisateur
le dernier rôle de marie trintignant
aura été celui d'une femme libre et
scandaleuse l'écrivain colette
oui c'est quelqu'un qui n'a qui n'a pas
peur de la vie qui n'a pas peur de
repartir à zéro et qui n'a pas
d'appréhension avec la ville la petite
marie voulais être vétérinaire mais dans
cette famille faire du cinéma c'est
héréditaire comme interpréter des rôles
militants en 1999 et les victoires à la
télévision elle défend la lutte des
femmes pour l'avortement
en tant que médecin gynécologue je sais
que les avortements clandestins
l'utilisation des sons des aiguilles à
tricoter diverses plantes et un réel
danger pour les femmes
le cinéma la télévision c'est le même
métier 10 est elle une affaire de femmes
en 92 de chabrol qui lui confie ensuite
le rôle phare de betty en 1996 a
commencé en 1996 elle rayonne dans le
cri de la soie en bella - shelter je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris
une dizaine de pièces deux surtout aux
côtés de son père conversation sur un
quai de gare et surtout poèmes à lou
d'apollinaire l'évidence et riche sans
la balle et douce odeur de violaines je
sens tu as presque imperceptible odeur
de muguet de décès
pour son premier rôle marie avec quatre
ans c'était mon amour mon amour
réalisé par sa mère